DO, THEY DO, AND THEY SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT.
>> Jason: AND I THINK THAT
THEY WILL BE, SHOULD JAMES COMEY
BE PROUD OF HIS CONDUCT?
JOINING US WITH MORE ON THE
PROGRESS, TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
JOHN RATCLIFFE, AND FORMER
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I SERVED WITH BOTH OF YOU IN THE
CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN RATCLIFFE, YOU ARE A
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY, TREY GOWDY
AND I SERVED WITH YOU.
WE LEFT YOU THERE TO YOUR
LONESOME ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU
HAVE HAD A DISCUSSION WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO, TELL US WHAT HAPPENED
AND WHAT TRANSPIRED.
>> JASON, TREY, GOOD TO SEE BOTH
OF YOU.
I DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET WITH INSPECTOR GENERAL
HOROWITZ LAST WEEK, WE TALKED
ABOUT HIS REPORT, THE TIMING,
NOT THE CONTENT.
AND HE REVEALED THAT HIS TEAM'S
INVESTIGATIVE WORK IS COMPLETE.
THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DRAFTING THE REPORT.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT IT WILL BE A
DRAFT COMPLETE IN SHORT ORDER.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT I DON'T
EXPECT THAT ANY OF US ARE GOING
TO SEE ANY TIME REAL SOON.
HE DID RELATE TO THAT AS MUCH AS
20% OF HIS REPORT IS PROBABLY
GOING TO INCLUDE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, SO THAT DRAFT
REPORT WILL HAVE TO UNDERGO A
CLASSIFICATION REVIEW AT THE FBI
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
SO, WHILE I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE
MIGHT SEE IT BEFORE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS RECESS FOR THE AUGUST
RECESS, I'M NOT TOO CERTAIN
ABOUT THAT.
>> Jason: THIS IS ALWAYS THE
FRUSTRATING THING THAT HAS
HAPPENED MULTIPLE TIMES WHERE WE
HAD REPORTS WHEN I WAS THE
CHAIRMAN, WHEN TREY GOWDY WAS
THE CHAIRMAN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WOULD REVIEW THINGS FOR
WEEKS ON END IF NOT MONTHS, BUT
IT IS ENCOURAGING TO KNOW THAT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS GOING
TO BE RIGHT THERE AROUND THE
CORNER.
CONGRESSMAN GAUDI, I HAVE TO
TELL YOU, YOU HAVE A VERY
DEFINITIVE JAMES COMEY, WHO
THINKS THAT HE DID EVERYTHING BY
THE BOOK AND THAT HE DID
EVERYTHING THAT HE WAS SUPPOSED
TO, BUT YOU AND CONGRESSMAN
RATCLIFFE ARE THE TWO PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW IF THAT EVENTUALLY
REVIEWED THE FISA UNREDACTED,
THE FISA REPORTS, IS
DIRECTOR COMEY RIGHT?
DID YOU DO EVERYTHING THE WAY
THAT HE WAS SUPPOSED TO?
>> JASON, I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
JAMES COMEY?
IS THAT THE COMEY THAT WROTE
THAT HE DID NOT LEAK IN A MEMO
THAT HE LEAKED?
IS THAT THE JAMES COMEY THAT
SAID HE DID NOT DO WEASEL THINGS
WHEN HE WAS MEMORIALIZING WHAT
HE SAID WAS A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION?
IS AT THE SAME JAMES COMEY THAT
SAID THAT THE FBI DID NOT GET A
GIVE A HOOT ABOUT POLITICS WHILE
HIS SENIOR AIDES DISCUSSED TWO
POLITICAL CANDIDATES THAT THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
INVESTIGATING?
THE SAME JAMES COMEY, THE ONE
THAT YOU JUST PLAYED?
THE SAME ONE?
>> Jason: YES, YES.
>> IT IS THE SAME ONE THAT TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BY SENDING FBI
AGENTS TO INTERVIEW MICHAEL
FLYNN WHILE HILLARY CLINTON HAD
A SMALL LAW FORM WHILE SHE WAS
INTERVIEWED.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WAS THE SAME JAMES COMEY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR WITS WILL
FIND, HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN HIM, HE IS A STRAIGHT ARROW,
BUT HE HAS JUST LOOKING AT THE
FISA ABUSE.
JOHN DURHAM IS LOOKING INTO WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE LATE WINTER AND
SPRING OF 2016.
SO YOUR VIEWERS HAVE TO HAVE A
LOT OF DEMARCATION.
JUST REMEMBER PETER STRZOK, IF
THAT NAME SOUNDS FAMILIAR, IN
JULY 2016 INITIATES A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS JULY OF 2016.
HORWITZ IS LOOKING AT THE FISA
PROCESS AFTER THAT.
JOHN DURHAM IS LOOKING AT THE
INVESTIGATION PRIOR TO THAT, AND
INVESTIGATION PRIOR TO THAT, ANI
AM HOPING THAT THOSE TWO
INVESTIGATIONS TOGETHER WOULD
SHED A LOT OF LIGHT.
SO AMERICA, THEY CAN KNOW WHAT
CAN HAPPEN, BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
A DIVISIVE TWO YEARS.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN
RATCLIFFE, YOU HAVE BEEN A U.S.
ATTORNEY, YOU AND TREY GOWDY
HAVE REVIEWED THE FISA REPORTS,
IT SAYS VERIFIED AT THE TOP.
AND I GUESS TO ME IF YOU WANT TO
DEBATE WHAT VERIFIED MEANS, BUT
YOU HAVE LOOKED AT THE
UNREDACTED REPORTS.
COMEY HAS SAID HE HAS DONE
EVERYTHING RIGHT, AND YOU SAID
IT WAS NOT DONE WRONG, BUT THAT
IT WAS DONE DECEPTIVELY, POORLY,
AND MAY BE EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION WAS LEFT OUT.
IT IS HORWITZ GOING TO BE THE
DEFINITIVE WORD?
WHAT IS HIS ROLE IN THE PROCESS?
>> I THINK THAT HE WILL BE ONE
OF THE MORE IMPORTANT VOICES.
IN A LOT OF FOLKS ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO BOB MUELLER'S
TESTIMONY ON JULY 17, COMING UP,
BUT BOB MUELLER WILL TALK ABOUT
COLLUSION THAT DID NOT EXIST.
AND WHAT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FOUND DID NOT EXIST.
YOU CAN ASK BOB MUELLER TEN
TIMES IN TEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES, AND I DON'T THINK
THERE WILL BE ANY NEW FACTS OR
NEW CONCLUSIONS.
BUT MICHAEL HORWITZ AND HIS
FINDINGS AND JOHN DURHAM AND HIS
FINDINGS, THOSE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT.
THOSE RELATE TO NOT ONLY TO
TRUMP MISCONDUCT, BUT POTENTIAL
OBAMA MISCONDUCT.
JIM COMEY SAYS THEY DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT, EVEN THOUGH AS
TREY POINTED OUT TO YOU HAVE A
LEAD INVESTIGATOR WHO PROMISED
TO STOP TRUMP.
WANTED TO PREVENT HIM FROM
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
HE HAD A DEPUTY DIRECTOR WHO
LIED UNDER OATH ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS AND WAS CRIMINALLY
REFERRED.
AS WAS POINTED OUT, DIRECTOR
COMEY HIMSELF LEAKED PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF
THE WORD PROUD, WHEN HE SAYS HE
IS PROUD OF ALL OF THAT WORK.
WE WILL FIND OUT.
MICHAEL HORWITZ, I DO THINK THAT
HIS FINDINGS WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT, JASON, BECAUSE IT
PRESENTS A REAL POTENTIAL
PROBLEM FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
RIGHT NOW WE ALREADY KNOW
BOB MUELLER HAS TOLD US THAT A
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION
STARTED AN INVESTIGATION INTO A
CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA THAT DID
NOT EXIST.
THAT IS BAD ENOUGH.
IT WOULD BE A WHOLE LOT WORSE IF
IT TURNS OUT THAT THAT SAME
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUED THAT INVESTIGATION BY
BREAKING RULES OF THE FISA
COURT.
IF THAT HAPPENS, YOU CAN PRETTY
MUCH PUT A PIN IN ANY
IMPEACHMENT BALLOON, BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE HARD FOR THE DEMOCRATS
TO SAY, WELL, WE STARTED AN
INVESTIGATION THAT WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE.
WE CONTINUED IT BY BREAKING THE
RULES, BUT WE WANT TO IMPEACH A
PRESIDENT FOR TRYING TO OBSTRUCT
THAT INVESTIGATION THAT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE STARTED.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN GOWDY,
LET'S GO BACK TO DIRECTOR
MUELLER WHO IS THERE TO TESTIFY.
YOU ARE NO LONGER ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD BE
QUESTIONING HIM.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS UP TO?
WHY WOULD THEY DO THIS?
IF YOU WERE ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE OF THE AISLE, WHAT KIND OF
QUESTIONS ARE YOU GOING TO ASK
MUELLER?
>> WELL, FIRST, THE EASY PART,
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS DOING IT?
THEY ARE NEVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BY THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THEY BROUGHT MICHAEL COHEN AND
JOHN DAIN AS EITHER FACT
WITNESSES OR EXPERTS, YOU
WOULD'VE BEEN EXCORIATED AS A
CHAIRMAN IF YOU HAD BROUGHT
TWO WITNESSES LIKE THAT, BUT
THEY HAVE A SAFETY NET.
THEY ARE NEVER CRITICIZED.
YOU ARE CALLING SOMEONE WHO DOES
NOT WANT THE CALL, WHO IS NOT
GOING TO DEVIATE FROM THE FOUR
CORNERS OF HIS REPORT -- OF SOME
OF US DID NOT EVEN THINK THAT
THE REPORT SHOULD BE PUBLIC.
WE SURE AS HELL DO NOT THINK YOU
SHOULD BE TESTIFYING.
BUT THEY GET A PASSPORT WHAT
SHOULD REPUBLICANS DO?
THEY SHOULD PREPARE.
YOU HAVE THE BEST LAWYER AT YOUR
DESK TONIGHT.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
JOHN RATCLIFFE, BUT THEY NEED TO
THINK OF TRENCHES OR BUCKETS,
WHAT DID HE FIND?
NOTE TERMINAL COLLUSION.
WHAT DID YOU NOT FIND?
AN INDICTABLE'S OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE DEFENSE.
WHAT DID HE NOT BOTHER TO LOOK
FOR?
JOHNNY MENTION COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN RUSSIA, WE
DO KNOW ONE CAMPAIGN WAS GETTING
DIRT FROM RUSSIA, DID MUELLER
BOTHER TO FIND OUT WHETHER THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT WAS FEEDING
THAT DIRT THROUGH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO
FUSION GPS?
DID HE EVEN ASK?
AND THE LEGAL ISSUE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, AND JOHNNY JUST
TOUCHED ON IT, IF YOU CAN RESIST
ON THE UNLAWFUL ARREST, CAN YOU
REALLY OBSTRUCT AND I'M
PREDICATED INVESTIGATION?
WHICH IT IS IMPORTANT WHERE
MUELLER BEGAN, AND I DON'T THINK
HE BEGAN BY FIGURING OUT THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE AS
IT RELATES TO TRUMP.
BUT WE WILL FIND OUT.
PREPARE, SET TO LOW
EXPECTATIONS, IT IS 5 MINUTES.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO UNLOCK THE
MYSTERIES OF THE WORLD IN
5 MINUTES.
I WISH THAT THEY WERE NOT HAVING
THE HEARING.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT WE GOT A
GOOD LAWYER LIKE JOHNNY
RADCLIFFE ON JUDICIARY.
>> Jason: YOU JUST POUR ALL OF
THE QUESTIONS INTO THAT BUCKET,
BUT GENTLEMEN, IT WAS A PLEASURE
AND AN HONOR TO SERVE WITH ALL
OF YOU.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.